we begin this morning with new
uncertainty over the Affordable Care Act
also known as Obamacare and the health
care coverage of millions of Americans
late Friday night a federal judge in
Texas ruled the law unconstitutional but
supporters of Obamacare are promising to
appeal the decision their concern the
ruling could strip coverage from
millions of Americans with pre-existing
conditions as a result a number of
insurance groups patient advocates and
health care providers denounced the
ruling despite the apparent victory for
the Trump administration the White House
says the Affordable Care Act will remain
in place while the issue plays out in
court Kenneth Craig joins us with the
details Kenneth good morning well good
morning to you the Affordable Care Act
has stood up to prior legislative and
legal challenges and has been upheld
twice by the Supreme Court but the judge
cited another landmark piece of
legislation passed just last year and
striking Obamacare down this time break
for our country great for the American
people thank you all it has been nearly
one year since President Trump signed
into law the tax cut bill passed with
zero Democratic votes in Congress and
now one part of the legislation is
impacting the future of the Affordable
Care Act the law eliminated the
individual mandate a penalty considered
attacks by the Supreme Court for anyone
who does not have health insurance in a
lawsuit backed by 19 Republican
attorneys general and one Republican
governor argues that since the penalty
has been eliminated
Obamacare is no longer constitutional in
a 55 page ruling judge Reed O'Connor
agreed writing the penalty can no longer
be fairly read as an exercise of
congress's tax power reaction to the
decision was swift Nancy Pelosi who is
likely to become Speaker when Democrats
take control of the House next month
called the ruling absurd and promised to
protect the affordable care act
meanwhile in an interview on Fox News
Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton touted
the decision as a victory he's one of
the lawsuits prominent backers we
believe from the very beginning was
unconstitutional
and we think the judge did the right
thing and President Trump tweeted his
satisfaction and called on Congress to
pass a new health care law and we're
gonna sign this bill since President
Obama signed the Affordable Care Act
into law in 2010 about 20 million people
have gained health insurance coverage
but the law has been frequently targeted
by Republicans both in Congress and in
the courts President Trump campaigned on
killing the Affordable Care Act and came
close but a repeal measure in the Senate
came up short when the late Arizona
Senator John McCain cast the decisive
vote the incoming Democratic majority in
the house could pass legislation of its
own keeping in place certain popular
provisions of Obamacare such as
protecting coverage for patients with
pre-existing conditions but a
republican-controlled Senate and
President Trump of course would have to
sign off on that and one last note today
is the enrollment deadline for anyone
seeking coverage under the Affordable
Care Act for 2019 Anthony important note
Kenneth thank you very much